each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone I'm JC cannon
partly covered privacy group when the
first things I want to do is apologize
for the heat there have been several
work requests in to sort of alleviate
the problem but for now we just have to
sort of get through this I'm running the
external privacy researcher program
which is a program that lets external
researchers work with Microsoft and
privacy related issues because dr.
africa vs winner of our elite members on
this team and what we're providing these
researchers is the opportunity to come
to microsoft and give presentations in
the area of privacy after the
presentation of course you're free to
correspond with him any questions you
might have or there's any related topics
you want to discuss without but feel
free to to email him directly to get to
this website you go to ms our web the
research area you know deter a security
and privacy list or category and
underneath there there's ms our privacy
and you get to the internal and external
privacy links to find out who's working
on privacy inside Microsoft and outside
of Microsoft now dr. Aphra copsa comes
to us from the University of California
via Germany he's actually been a
professor in Germany at the University
of I'm sorry Essen thank you very much
he is also on director of the research
institute over there the center for
information technology his research lies
the area of user modeling and
personalized systems privacy and it's
also the editor of user modeling and
user adapted interaction
I'll bring his presentation up and I
welcome dr. Aphra kobza thank you very
much can you hear me I mean that's quite
sure but I think it's all all right I
first like to give a brief survey of
personalization and privacy issues that
are related to personalization please
alert me if it gets too basic so
personalization is already there a while
ago for is the research did a small
survey on what kind of personalization
elements you can currently find on the
weapons they found well tailored email
alerts people sign up for certain
information by email customized content
like your preferred stocks on some
portal recommendations like Amazon
Express transactions targeted marketing
yes
now they looked at the top thousand
websites and summarized what each
website offered so the percentages add
up to more than hundred it's also a few
years old now we only bring too far more
personalization like web courses they
tailored to each individual student
information recommendation on handheld
devices that's already here in a jar
product descriptions get nowadays more
and more geared towards the knowledge of
each individual visitor we already have
personalized search our media
preferences get more and more taking the
account and we also have recommendation
on the web it's already quite a few
websites that use this so
personalization is already part of the
web to the extent that people already
expect it there is a couple of nice
anecdotes that people believed it was
personalization wide actually there was
no personalization going on so people
kind of already get used to it
in 30 seconds how this personalization
work essentially it's based on two types
of data first data that the user
explicitly supplies and probably even
more importantly logs of web pages that
user visits actions that user performs
on that pages and there's three groups
of methods in one researchers HCI
experts first look at the people who
access websites and group them into
different subgroups and determine that
needs preferences etc and when a new
visitor comes the website tries to
allocate this person to one or more of
these subgroups and then geared to the
needs of specific groups another is
simple rules or business rules if the
user does this and this in this or
enters this in this in this then do the
following can be sometimes quite complex
but it's usually also handmade soap
reanalysis and then hard coded rules in
the third area and it's a huge area as
machine learning where websites learn
about certain user characteristics make
inferences about user characteristics so
there is surely
hundreds of different methods that are
currently being used in personalization
are and the big competition is what
methods are suited other forward purpose
some assignment for the group is there
also by machinery necklace it can be
done yes the traditional way is that's
how it started out is to pre analyzed
but of your course you can do some sort
of test analysis you can do both so
there's variety of approaches there is
already studies that show that
personalization delivers benefits to
both that visitors but also to websites
that offer personalization so those were
mostly made in 98 99 by market research
firms so true Peter found that the
number of visitors increased it
personalized websites which is nice but
does not say very much Neil's and found
that visitors stayed longer also that
more visitors are turned into buyers
than a regular web sites Gardner
predicted that by 2003 eighty-five
percent of all the top thousand websites
would have some element of
personalization included and we'll show
a video are they particularly idea my
hunch they were not right by 2003 but
now by 2005 probably yes if any little
detail counts yes program at Jupiter
three years later after the boom the
reference retrospective analysis and
found yes but personalized sites cost
four times more than regular sites and
few users indicate that personalization
would make them buy but nevertheless
they do buy
so there is some research that shows
that recommendation crust recommendation
does for at least for some confidence
based on your research and he sends
about how much of this day would still
agree with like Jupiter 68 that today
what they said then it's still pretty
much on target or
I mean it's hard to replicate their
study because top websites now do have
elements of personalization or built in
so you cannot compare non-personalized
with personalized sites very much
anymore unless you go to in frequently
visited sites and again here it's hard
to make up Harrison our return on
investment great four times as much to
operate but um you know Amberson this
cross recommendation people who bought
this also bought this generates income
yes exactly the official number from the
chief signed former chief scientist is
more than twenty percent additional
revenues that's the answer i just gave
you amazon says officially more than
twenty percent at on revenues by cross
recommendation the in official numbers
that they have heard from him a higher
than twenty percent yeah essentially
compensate them for the additional this
i don't know but if it would be the case
they wouldn't do it they do all sorts of
experiments you probably notice it
yourself once in a while things have met
amazon they simply play with their
millions of users and if things don't
work they wouldn't apply it to the broad
audience the other question indicator
powerfully
3 which is the cause in which everything
I I questioned the whole study in itself
yeah I just wanted to be fair not to
only bring positive nodes because we
will hear later asking people is a good
start up but it does not necessarily
give you the right answer or the full
answer yeah now the downside big
downside personalized sites collect far
more personal data balance the
individuals than regular websites and as
a matter of fact personalization is
based on personal data and as we all
know there is currently a big concern of
Internet users about their privacy
online so they have also been numerous
studies being done in the early 2000s by
many organizations so it's a market
research consulting firm is the american
association of retired people IBM did a
study across several countries are the
numbers differ a little bit but in total
they all show that that if you ask
people they all express a concern or
even a strong concern about the bulging
personal personal information online
being tracked they are not only
concerned but they claim that they only
took actions in the past like leaving
websites that required registration
information having entered faked
registration information so you're not
alone having refrained from shopping
specifically here in the US
ah but would imprinted will be willing
to give out theater if they got
something valuable in return so these
studies look I mean interesting but
they're five years old or and so much
has changed five years since
yeah all studies consistent so that was
the big boom of studies in the early
2000s they were still studies made 2004
and I'm aware of one study 2005 all of
them consistently show that if you ask
people then they tell you they are very
much privacy concerns etc etc I will
later I will the way I'm phrasing is
very careful as you notice i will later
show that asking people about privacy
concerns is not the only possible maybe
not the best way of finding out about
privacy related issues and there's
already a couple of studies that
demonstrate this yeah
there is studies that show that certain
data is more easily divulged than others
are there is gender differences so
location information man are much more
willing to divulge for a phone number
and address than women are there is a
difference whether you ask people will
they should about their own data are
those of their children so yes there is
differences in the types of tater and
people stated willingness to give them
out however there is again mentioned if
you run experiments where you put people
in a situation ah then you can see that
what people do often often differs
widely from what people stated
previously they would do also there is
at least three experiments that we way
of where this has been clearly
demonstrated
okay now personalization requires
personal data and people are reluctant
to give out personal data if you ask
them so is this an either/or situation
it's their fundamental conflict between
personalization and privacy there is
some discussion in the literature at
least in the online literature marketing
literature our answer is it's not simple
as this either or but rather the answer
is more complex and here's a kind of
quick summary of what the answer is I
will later given model that justifies
the ends a little bit more and also show
an experiment that motivates that this
answer most is valuable and all this is
kinds of the foundation of approach that
I point privacy in a enhanced
personalization and essentially the
starting point is that you respect users
privacy no matter whether this is users
individual privacy preferences or if
you're in a country in the state that
has privacy legislation enacted the
respective privacy laws or there is also
industry privacy agreements if you sign
up for privacy seals nowadays these
organization to not only sign off that
you match what you claim you would do
but rather you also have to maintain
minimum privacy standards so start out
with respecting all this then the second
thing you should definitely do is to
provide benefits there is studies
already the show no matter where they
have good a bad privacy it also matters
what your benefits are you
provide including personalization within
the constraints that are possibly set by
respecting people's privacy but try to
personalize in an optimal manner within
this constraint space then increasing
uses understanding also seems to be very
important I'll show you this later so
don't do too much magic surprising the
user once in the wine is fine but in
general only two things that users
understand if you suspected users don't
understand it then provide an
explanation so Amazon resorted to that
the while ago all this will increase
users trust and then kind of be patient
it's not a one-shot thing but rather
this is a process users always start out
to be very cautious and over the time
they gain trust and if you make it clear
to users ah what the benefits are and
short-term benefits are better than
long-term benefits it's already very
well established immediate gratification
is quite important then user themselves
will come forward with their data
permissions
and based on that on the additional data
on the additional permissions you should
provide what you promised here so
increase the benefits so it's a kind of
cycle a loop or it has to do with
relationship building in the most
general sense I'm going to show you a
little experiment that gives some
indications that this basic position is
worthwhile it's an experiment on how you
should convey the privacy practices of
your company and as you know the
standard way of convey or conveying the
privacy practices to users is to publish
it privacy policy of privacy statement
if you ask users again large number
finds them very important much number of
respondents feel that it makes them more
comfortable providing personal
information seventy-three percent of
respondents claim that they viewed
privacy policies in the past twenty six
percent claimed that they always view
privacy policies if you look at the
server side you will morph fine figures
far less than one percent so there is
such a discrepancy between what people
state they do and what they effectively
do this is no wonder because there is
already findings from reading sciences
that privacy policies are written in a
manner that this who's reading level is
far higher than what should be this has
to do with the fact that privacy
this is a very important legal documents
so companies can be sued if they do not
behave as the state in the this document
so we tried to come up with a different
approach to conveying to people are what
a company will do with the data and our
approach is that we claim that every
website should have printed two elements
one is a link to a traditional privacy
policy so we do not want to get rid of
the traditional privacy policies are
mostly not for legal reasons there is an
important little hard for that which we
cannot replace completely but we say
that in addition to privacy policies are
websites for each and every entry field
should provide very clear and context
specific information on why this data is
solicited and what benefits users will
incur when they provides this data so
all in all these may amounts to breaking
up this huge document to tiny pieces
that are related to the specific entry
fields in the field until you see an
example
he is a question and here the user gets
an explanation of what benefits he or
she can expect from answering this
question and here is an explanation of
how the company is going to treat this
information and the same thing for each
and every question that the system poses
and this comes in addition to the
traditional privacy link so essentially
what we did here we grabbed this privacy
policy and looked what are the most
important sentences from this privacy
policy and kind of summarized these
sentences here in a more comprehensive
manner
now this is a nice proposal is this
proposal any good and in order to find
this out we ran an experiment where we
compared the site that had the
traditional design and it is a site that
had more this design and we did is in in
Berlin in Germany where I'm currently on
a sabbatical and so it was a German but
it's exactly the same what you saw
before here is the link to the privacy
policy here are the questions I'm sorry
mix those up here are the questions and
here is the context specific privacy
disclosure there is an additional
element here that we introduced for the
purposes of our experiment name is
so-called selection calendar which is
1,000,000 here we pretended that the
system at this point would be able to
recommend a million books to the user I
explain you later for what purpose we
needed that and back to this here here
is the very same site but without this
additional contextual explanation for
each and every question
one quick intermission why did we run an
experiment why didn't we ask people
which site they preferred and that's for
exactly the reason that I mentioned
before we already have experiences in
the area of privacy that there is a
conflict divergence between what people
tell you out of context and what people
actually do if you put them into a
specific context and let them act it
seems the people in general are not so
good to answer privacy related question
out of context in an abstract manner but
they are usually quite good in acting
you know half way consistent manner if
you put them into a certain complex
this does not rule out inquiry based
studies for privacy at all also we
essentially we did both are but it's
very important also to make
observational studies in HCI
we announced this experiment as a kind
of test for a new version of well-known
online bookstore we never told the name
of the online bookseller but we made
sure that people could guess who it
would be we pretended that this new
version would be able to make
recommendations ah but would have to ask
people about a number of questions we
pointed out that people had no
obligation to ask to answer any question
we warned them that data would be
supplied to the company we pointed out
that at the end the system would make
recommendations and people would have
the opportunity to buy one book out of
the recommended books for this count of
seventy percent so people in some ways
had an incentive to provide true answers
in order to shrink down and to tailor
they recommended looks better to the
interest because then they could buy a
discounted book from those and we also
warned them that if they would buy the
book then they would have to supply bank
data and identification data and also
show us their ID and also their egg
credentials also there was a kind of you
will see this late again a step between
anonymous recommendation and then
deciding to buy a book whereupon people
had to identify themselves
we had 32 questions several of them
aloud from yeah
I know but at least we knew where the
name and address information was correct
the reason why we did that is we wanted
to pretend a to avoid that people could
kind of give real interest data but
avoid having to reveal their true
identity by giving a different shipping
address girlfriend or whatever so if
they wanted to buy a book then they
really had to stand up for the data so
to speak of celebra 32 questions some
questions allowed for multiple answers
but not all answer combinations made
sense so the maximum reasonably possible
and this was 64 most questions where
values interests some very sensitive
like users literary sexual preferences
or medical interests including mineral
diseases and things like that all
questions made sense in the context of
book recommendation we took very much
care of that and if people answered
questions this visibly decreased this
selection counter which was completely
fake but people could see okay at the
start it's a hundred thousand books
million books that are being recommended
now it's just fifty thousand nights two
thousand so they could see a progress
and again they had an incentive at the
end to have a small selection set so
that their interests are being carefully
matched
then in the third phase and people are
still anonymous in this phase they got
would be claimed to be their personal
book recommendations these were 50 books
but everyone gets the same got the same
set of 50 bucks of they were selected
based on the price also the interest
similarly interest for students so
popular fiction politics travel guides
health advisories sex supplies or things
like that and they were visibly marked
down and also there was the standard
Amazon information available on each of
these 50 books and now people have to
decide to did they want to buy one of
these books for high discount and
thereby they had to reveal the identity
or rather not and those who decided to I
your ask for names shipping address and
also bank information we verified this
data so was it disclosed
we left this open but we want them at
the beginning that all the data would be
available to Emerson to excuse me to the
to the company that is behind this study
we deliberately left a little bit I'm
nonnamous Elsa to make it as a potential
All England uh yeah presumably also put
it the other way around there was
nothing that could directly implicates
that there was a differentiation between
non-identifiable data and identifiable
it was one system and it was one
experiment and there was no break in
between i distinguish is here for
presentation purposes
ok and then they've completed a
questionnaire and we verify the data and
this was done with students from
Humboldt University a half of them were
assigned to one version and the other to
the other version of the system and our
starting hypothesis was that people in
the second condition where they got
additional explanation about what is
being done with the data what is the
privacy policy of the company with
respect to each specific field data
field ah that and what are the benefits
from providing this data that these
people would provide more data and this
is also the result but we got
interestingly enough more than what we
asked for so if you count the questions
that were answered this is current
systems just with the privacy policy
this is what we suggested privacy policy
plus contextual explanation for each and
every question then there was a eight
percent increase in the questions
answered which is the district is
significant if you look at the answers
that were given some answers aloud Alex
with some questions allowed for more
than one answer then there's a twenty
percent increase
interesting enough if you look at the
number of people who eventually decided
to buy a book there's significant
increase which is approaching
significance now so people also bought
more books despite the fact that
everyone got the same books recommend it
yes yes oh you're approaching
based on your velvety small sample size
of yes yeah so that's we didn't ain't no
why yes how do they are they randomized
they were randomized just randomly
assigned to one of these conditions yeah
are we didn't specifically but it turned
out it's the most balanced Chandler a
background we didn't check very much it
was a relatively homogeneous population
though they were students in a business
management public administration school
them so it was in let's say an educated
section of the general population you
know the reverse of the words
counterbalance it well we better try I
mean we cannot repeat it expert we would
have loved to do it within subjects alia
but unfortunately can't do it yeah
what I think is a really
I think this is the very first one with
oh yeah
subset of a million that you started
with I didn't give you any information
I feel really comfortable
are quite frankly we have no explanation
for it we were heading for this so our
theory is that's what I presented before
if we respect people's privacy but do a
little bit more incrementally then you
will get people to become more open to
provide answers if you see benefit from
it and so actually this was the result
we were targeting at this was we were
more looking at buying under the
perspective that in order to buy you
have to reveal your identity data so
actually we were more interested in how
many people are willing to give out the
names addresses connected with all the
preferences that gave before that the
gate before so we're not that's nice
that people bought more but for us it
was more interested that they were
willing to go so far to disclose the
identity and under this aspect it's
quite interesting and this would also be
our prime explanation if it were the
purchase were completely free that
people simply reveal the identities to
large extent because their fear of
disclosure was kind of counterbalance by
the benefit that they got now they had
to pay a little bit on top of this book
pro religious negligible
what is also interesting is attitudinal
questions that we ask of course more
people believe in the second condition
that privacy has priority our bathers
used responsibly but interestingly
enough more people in the second
condition believe that data allowed
store to select better books what did
you ask them easily will you have
afterwards afterwards but isn't it based
and
but everyone got the same random nothing
do it better but in both conditions
everyone got the same books but
nevertheless in the second condition so
if we gave all these contextualized
explanations then twenty percent had a
better impression let's call it of the
service quality of the store even though
the service was objectively the same and
that's that's quite interesting here we
have no clear answer to that here the
identity of revealing might be the
answer here we more belief that the
general perception of this store
extended to the service quality but we
have nothing to back this up this is
actually also an unintended side result
yeah so did you find it incentive
to buy samples our a discount discount
seventy percent discount ER and they so
before the development do you tell them
well this is a small bookstore there
which is pretty good don't worry about
point some construction is good
otherwise people may think that well you
know they credit hug you away my summer
school first of all awesome what kind of
judging people
we told them that at the end they would
have the possibility to purchase one of
the recommended books for high discount
we sell it seventy percent is governor
so then you right from the beginning
that they would be rewarded if they
could ensure that the recommendations
fits the interests which we think
product them to give truthful answers
this data it appears that giving the
textual explanation helps them get a
better understanding but you didn't test
whether they would get dissolve there
more to read out of the middle say it
again well if you didn't test the
hypothesis that the users would have
more to read and then stop answering
questions if they have the option yeah
there's many things that we didn't test
yeah so it's kind of a spot sell the
sweet spot
from this we should conclude that
explanations are unquestionably
desirable I mean put it this way they
don't hurt ya so in the policy of
privacy enhanced personalization they're
definitely good the more is we are a
principal from HCI increased
understanding increases users trust in
the system yeah in a generic Gundam and
from this I derived acclaim from for
privacy enhance personalization make
things clear to users
well students right so our biggest
challenge around
basis for where every word
yeah yeah I'm happy with this however
educated people out the most privacy
concerns group of people in the US it's
additionally the elderly people who are
generally in the top privacy concerns
category so we picked a a group that
generally reveals a relatively high
privacy concern attitude for people
don't normally think about privacy could
you make privacy market differentiator
right
you know making aware of even the
privacy issues suddenly they become more
interested if you put in the right way
and if you did it right you sever become
the preferred way they do be commerce
several people asked several people
asked this question already we have no
definite answer but I mean one-third
increase in sale might be an interesting
indication yeah yeah so to give a better
answer to your question one would have
to replicate this experiment maybe with
some support yes I mean it's not the
task of academia any maurya to do this
on a broader basis but definitely yes
also I mean there's a couple of other
problems here that I didn't discuss your
site reputation is the effect the same I
mean amazon.de which we used has a good
reputation we tested for that it ranks
top in a number of 10 names that we gave
ah can we replicate the same for less
known sites at the answer to this is yes
we did this in the mean time for the
site where we make sure that its
reputation is lower in that of Amazon
and got similar results so we have the
same effect that our disclosures have a
positive
impact on question and drink but also
purchase behavior Emerson thought he has
a very good privacy policy so
intuitively speaking putting this up for
making this one visible to users we
don't do this we don't do this we don't
do this it's actually good for the
company what if your company has a less
stringent privacy policy will making
this more visible also increase people's
procuracy to answer questions probably
not but we would like to find this out
then this relates to question before all
these explanations occupy quite a lot of
screen real estate if web designers tell
us that's impossible we can't waste so
much face put this in the second layer
so have an icon explanation and then
explanation a persona we just having one
second at the bomb that person it
doesn't make it very long we didn't look
at that we didn't look at that we just
wanted to look at the form that we felt
will be most effectual and then have
kind of variance and to the slowly one
by one so this is a very interesting
question from a commercial point of view
will the availability of explanations
but only in a second layer have the same
effect
and also we are a little bit concerned
about legal ramifications what we
present is actually just as quick
summary of what the company is doing now
if we have a footnote a kind of small
print read the full disclosure for full
information we already used to look at
something like that with a little bit of
skepticism so do we need an explicit
reference to a full disclosure and if so
will people become a little bit more
cautious if we have this so all this is
still unclear
and so finally I give you this model
that I promised it has trust in the
center and it's let's call it my
personal summary of the current
consensus in the literature on privacy
trust etc and personalization how things
interact I start out here a
personalization if users perceived
benefits and again immediate benefits
are much better than long-term benefits
this will interest will increase users
trust and more trust leads to more
willingness of people to disclose
personal data which usually leads to
bail personalization so in general the
more data you have about people the
better you will be able to provide
personalized into action so this is a
kind of positive feedback loop perceives
benefit surely increases people's
willingness to buy but of course there's
many many other factors also that
contribute to that
now understanding also increases trust
that's known from HCI if control
increases trust it's also known from HC
I perceived privacy most likely also
increased increases trust are there were
several experiments conducted in the MIS
literature um control of data most
likely increases perceived privacy and
we with our experiment work mostly on
the understanding level so explaining
things to people and specifically a
explaining privacy matter to people and
also by giving them the option of not
answering questions at all we gave them
some sort of feel of control so probably
that's how I that's where our experiment
worked we did nothing here so we had no
personalization in the system but
nevertheless people felt that
personalization benefits which is quite
interesting
um I will leave it like this or if you
have questions this yes
if your interest is key know there's a
workshop coming up during the tie
conference before the kind conference in
Montreal and JC's on the prom committee
so it's worthwhile going there this is
for people who do research in this area
or want to do research in this area want
to talk with colleagues about their
experiences
so if there's a puzzle to be there where
that they stop there must be something
that
that hinder sure yeah it's not the
linear function but somehow I don't know
yes it's it is catchy model a' don't
regard it as it doesn't show you don't
regard it as a model theoretic proud but
just that what has effect on what other
factors are and if you look at that like
this this kind of enforces also the view
that personalization and privacy is not
a one-shot thing but rather it's a
process it's about there's the word
customer relationship management and
this is part of it
so a proactive privacy policy is
according to this experiment very useful
and there is nothing wrong in putting
privacy up front so when I came here to
Microsoft the reception calendar I saw a
note about the privacy policy with
regard to being tracked as a visitor
that's good not only the reception desk
but also seemingly on websites that want
people to provide date in all of the day
I can give better recommendations
there's some factors like credit car
you're probably those whistles only
fifty dollars because otherwise
some sort of limit for the rest then
maybe her people let's get on the
privacy yeah yeah so there was a study
by an old study by acumen and Craner who
asked people specifically these kinds of
data to whom would you about yourself
your children secret spouse with me and
mistaking when would you give them out
and there's clearly a tendency that
there are data that are less sensitive
and data that are more sensitive so one
can loosely rank data it varies between
so there you it varies between people
but there is the average values are
relatively constant we also do this
little analysis what contributed to
people increase answers is it that
people are y is their pattern do people
generally answer all questions more
frequently or specific questions that
people answer more frequently and we
found that both is true so there is a
tendency that people seem to give more
answers or answer more questions but
it's always a little bit focused on
these sensitive questions that I
mentioned so people's literary sexual
preferences but neither of those is
statistically significant but when one
sees it trends that it goes both ways
yep solution focused on explicitly
provided information
a lot of recommendations
so if you have any
that are derived from
this
you're so our general claim but this
experiment doesn't address it that
providing privacy information will both
make people more willing to explicitly
provide data but also make them more
willing to give permission to science
collecting data about themselves so this
approach does not say very much about
the specific mechanism that you use but
rather about people's attitude with
respect to letting the company use such
data and we feel that it will go both
ways both with respect to explicit data
and implicitly with a client data
we have some completely different line
of research with that I skipped here
which may be interesting for you if you
have um at a given point several
possible personalization methods several
algorithms that you could use which vary
in their privacy implications so some
only use demographic data some use
explicitly provided data some use
implicit data we try to come up with a
system architecture that allows us to at
any given point to use the best
personalization methods that are
permitted under the given privacy
constraints and these privacy
constraints are specified by users what
they tell us they don't want to do want
the privacy laws that may possibly apply
although industry regulations so we are
working on an architecture that gives
each and every user his personalized
architecture that contains methods only
that are permitted under the given
privacy constraints and we work with a
product line approach that allows to do
this in an efficient manner and also to
combined users that have the same
privacy constraints this is not only
interesting from the point of view that
different people may have different
privacy preferences but there's also now
quite a lot of international privacy
laws and many privacy laws also subject
foreign sites to the national privacy
laws that is if you're have a site
saying the gas even though there's no
national privacy law in the US you may
be subject to different national laws if
you sell to people abroad for instance
Australia has such a law also European
Union to some extent and so you hear it
also becomes more and more interesting
to have a privacy enforcement that is
very much tailored to each individual
user
alright thank you very much for those
who joined us late you can find out
information about alpha cops are at our
external private researchers site hold
on hold on let me just log in real quick
hey